-We're here with Jennifer Lopez.
Her new movie "Marry Me"
is in theaters February 11th.
And I should mention that I have
a cameo in this movie.
-You do have a cameo.
-We're in a movie together.
-Two cameos.
-I know. I had two cam--
Pretty important scenes.
-Really important scenes.
Actually, one of the scenes
was really important.
It was very emotional.
Because it's one
of those moments
where, like,
people don't get to see
where I kind of had to, like,
let down my guard, too,
where she suffers this terrible
kind of public humiliation
and is on her way home.
And like the night talk show
hosts do, they're roasting her.
And she's crying on the floor
in a puddle.
You know what I mean?
And it's just, like,
one of those moments
that people don't
really think about.
You know, you don't think,
"Oh, God.
Maybe they're laughing at home.
Maybe they can take a joke."
And sometimes it just --
-It just hurts.
-It just hurts, yeah.
And this was the first time,
like, I got to, like, do that.
Because, you know,
we're in show business.
We like to
put our best foot forward.
We're out here. You don't need
to know about our nonsense.
You just sing the song,
do the dance.
We entertain.
We have a good time.
But there's a human being there,
and I think this movie
kind of gets into that.
And you are the talk show host
who's roasting me.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that I got permission
to roast your character, yeah.
But I do think you are perfect
for that
'cause you get to see
all the stuff.
And it's such public stuff.
Everything you do is so public,
'cause you're that famous.
-Yes.
-So, you're having a concert.
You have a very public breakup.
-Yeah.
-And someone, being Owen Wilson,
is in the crowd
and has a sign up.
-Who is so good in this movie!
Oh, my God, you will love him
in this movie.
-He knows how to do it, right?
He knows how to do it.
-He just grounds
the whole thing.
He's just so amazing.
He just has
so much heart and soul.
We're so different.
And we're supposed to be.
We're supposed to be.
-Opposites attract.
-Yes, yes.
-Well, basically,
you're just fed up,
and someone's holding a sign up
at a concert, like you do.
And his says, "Marry me,"
and you go, "Okay."
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like, wait,
what just happened?
-Nothing else is working out.
How about this?
-"Okay, I'm gonna marry you."
-Let's do it.
-"You want to get married?
Let's just do it."
And he's like, "What?"
-Yeah, and it turns into
a whole frenzy with social media
and everything that happens,
and it gets out.
-It's a great idea.
-Yeah. It's fun.
-Do you have any memorable signs
that you see
when you have your concerts?
-So many.
-Yeah.
I mean, I think when I first --
I went on tour pretty late
in my career.
I didn't go
until I was in my 40s
and I had kids
and everything like that.
And so I hadn't tour for like --
I don't know how many.
12 years I had been
recording music,
and I had never done
a proper world tour.
I'd done shows, of course,
here and there always.
But I remember this woman
holding up this sign
and saying, "I've been
waiting 14 years."
Oh, my God,
it's gonna make me cry.
She said -- She said,
"I've been waiting for 14 years
to tell you that you helped me
be the woman that I am today."
I was like, "Oh, my God."
-That's cool, right?
That's powerful.
Because I had never toured --
It was so sweet.
It was just like
you don't realize,
like, your music
is touching people.
You just think you're just
doing this thing.
We do this thing,
and you don't realize that
until you, like, tour the world
and people come up to you,
and I would do
the meet and greets,
and they would, you know,
tell me, like --
show me tattoos of my name
on their back.
And so I'm like,
"What is happening here?"
And it was just amazing
to see it.
So that was
a very memorable sign.
I always think about that.
-I'm so happy you're here.
Congrats on the film.
And thanks for performing
tonight with Maluma.
-Yes! We perform.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's the clip
from the movie "Marry Me."
-Okay, now, I'm guessing
from the way you're holding that
that you haven't done
too much bowling.
-Uh, what do I do?
-Well, you're gonna want to put
your fingers in the holes there.
Yeah, get your thumb
in that one.
-There, that one?
-Yep. And then take three steps.
Kind of you want
to land on your left,
and don't be afraid
to use those little --
-Strike is better than a spare,
right?
-That is not
your first time bowling.
-Yes!
Did you get that?
-Come on!
Little rope-a-dope.
-Oh, my God,
I wish I put money on this,
because people are loving it.
-What people?
-Oh, this is
an Instagram Live feed,
and 237,000 people are like,
"Why is he such a boring nerd?"
-Mel.
-What? Their words, not mine.
-[ Laughs ]
It's so well done and modern
and cool and great direction.
The director is Kat Coiro.
Unbelievable.
Congrats on this movie.
You know I love you.
-Thanks.
-Jennifer Lopez, everybody.
"Marry Me" is in theaters
February 11th
and streaming on Peacock.